che cos'è questo suono che le settimane
passate ha determinato tanta eccitazione
del mondo che ha prodotto articolo di
giornale negli stati uniti in india in
europa pressioni in italia che è andato
oltre i giornali terapisti è nato nel
senso comune da non parlare dei giornali
di calcio oppure in youtube sono alcuni
file di malati le ricette di cucina
oppure anche nell'agro come comici della
littizzetto o negli stati uniti a lecce
beh sicuramente avete capito parliamo
gli umbri gravitazionali
prima di parlare di un leader nazionali
partendo dall'inizio da tanto tempo fa
partiamo da poco e conosciamo
dell'universo
noi conosciamo dell'universo che la
parte che noi comprendiamo è regolata da
quattro interazioni fondamentali abbiamo
interazioni nucleare forte chi è quella
che l'insieme it work nei nucleoni e
l'interazione nucleare deboli che è
quella che tende a rompere tutte inutili
quindi file
poi abbiamo l'interazione tra magnetica
che caratterizzo agli atomi le molecole
infine abbiamo un interazione per
canzonare interazione gravitazionale
quella presente non morta ma presente un
uomo serio l'antichità si è sempre
scontrato lanciava un sasso questo
cadere a terra lui meritava di saltare
certi colato quindi l'uomo ha sempre
combattuto contro le interazioni
gravitazionali e ha cercato di capirlo
affidabilità chi ha fatto una
osservazione rimasta valida per sé
nell'interazione per nazionale è stata
ristori aristotele disse che il moto
verso il basso di una massa di modo di
piombo
nicolino in qualunque altro porto dotato
di peso è tanto più veloce quanto
maggiori sono le sue dimensioni
quindi io credo in sasso che come faccio
a stare entrare in b è praticamente un
giocatore dell'inter hodza a
quindi questa osservazione è stata
ritenuta maglia per secoli è stata
ritenuta parità nel secoli fino a che
non incontriamo il primo uomo in questo
talk che è andato oltre e questo nuovo e
galileo galileo del 636 era agli arresti
domiciliari perché già aveva un dato
troppo lui aveva preso il cannocchiale
aveva guardato il cielo e da lì aveva
capito che la teoria eliocentrica
propria piaga della solita di questo
compiaceva ed era stato quindi
condannato agli arresti domiciliari era
stato condannato alla view da condannato
a non dover più studiare la storia è
però che verrà facile
e nel momento in cui gli arresti
domiciliari è tornata un vecchio amore
perché volevo incanta e scrisse la sua
opera massima agli arresti che dialogo
sopra i due massimi sistemi
in questa opera tre personaggi come
parodia le storie e di aristotele diceva
leggo perché in italiano ufficile adesso
al 13 una palla di ferro di 100 libbre e
cadendo dall'altezza di 100 caccia
arriva a terra prima che una di una vita
sia scesa di un solo braccio
io dico che nelle arrivano allo stesso
tempo voi trovate nel farne esperienza
che la maggiore al pc ma in più di te la
minore cioè che quando alla grande per
quante la terra l'altra lontana di
brevità ora vorreste dopo queste dedita
a piazzarle 99 bracciali aristotele che
parlando solo del mio minimo errore
mettere sotto silenzio l'altro massimo
ora questo testo in italiano dico un po
difficile ricordate è la base del
pensiero scientifico perché voi vedete
che parla nel farne esperienza quindi
galileo immediamente dice l'esperienza
la prova sperimentale ma c'è un elemento
il concetto di onore sperimentale
io la faccio affermazione questa non è
perfettamente salta nella misura però
risulta essere prossima il mio lettore
sperimentale è molto più grande e
dell'errore che voi conigliette e se
credete a destra
questa è la fase di attenzione
scientifico moderno e questa
affermazione di candeo e diciamo ha
trovato molte persone che hanno cercato
di dimostrarlo lui direttamente ci ha
provato diciamo per difficoltà spedita
lido
ne segue che hanno provato la prova
ovviamente la prova più spettacolare di
una parte la fase degli americani
e infatti nel 1971 e il comandante dei
ris coop
guardate nella missione apollo 11 premi
perché davanti alle telecamere sulla
luna prende in una mano un martello
nell'alto una più matura di falcone
perché la sua storia testimonia falcon e
il fa la prova da parte del proprietario
e quindi si vede una delle cabine e fa
questo appello e una prima a castro
esattamente con la stessa velocità e
quindi aveva arrivato giorni ora
dobbiamo aspettare questa prova del
dimostrante è un certo effetto fa e chi
però dopo che andremo a veramente
strutturato la nostra visione classica
della cavitazione è stato aiuto newton e
una colonna della fisica classica io
dove ha fatto la teoria della
gravitazione universale ha fatto delle
leggi del moto la meccanica classica le
orbite dei pianeti delle comete e ha
studiato una luce è affatto una
conversione fissa tra la sterlina è un
calcolo inferis mai problemi moto per
dirmi qualcosa ha sbagliato e e erano
così importante suoi tempi che quando
molin epitaffio è a dir poco altisonante
le tratte dal finder po per la natura e
leggi della natura la cedola nascoste
nella notte gli disse che io non sia e
luce
e ora la teoria di newton e la teoria
della gravitazione che lo siamo
costretti nei nostri saperi
studiamo piccole correzioni usando la
meccanica classica in moto dei pianeti
uguali le carie thalassia tramite
piccoli si vola però latteria di newton
anche un vulnus principale fondamentale
vulnus che ne ha già poco piacevole per
per utah nel tempo ma sicuramente è
diventato molto documento
l'elettromagnetismo è diventato che li
ha poi la funzione dell'interazione di
distanza è istantaneo di trazione la
realizzazione di torriana
se una disfunzione massa cambiava il suo
aspetto qui l'effetto è immediato il
tutto l'universo e questo non può
funzionare un po funzionare cambio
dentro ma il ritmo giusto materia solida
robusta e in questo anno pari delle
tematiche sono troppi parlerò ne parlo
di due soli 1 non cito marshall che
grazie alle sue fazioni
noi conosciamo strutturiamo
perfettamente la nostra conoscenza delle
traditore emozioni max sono poi alla
base della ferriera diventare mister
italia stanno quindi l'importanza
fondamentale ma la clinica digitale e
mario farc vado perché ha dato la
risposta che ogni ricercatore vorrebbe
dare a chi fa la domanda curiosa per un
ricercatore specie di pancetta di base a
che serve questo scegliamo sempre la
risposta di fare dei fumo interessante
fare il pane dell'induzione
elettromagnetica l'induzione magnetica è
alla base del conseguente dei motori
elettrici della generazione emergente
come di perché per l'importanza parte e
quando li può del ministro delle finanze
linguistiche
ma questa che serve la risposta fu io
non lo so ma sicuramente il suo
cooperando c entra la tassa
forse quel copernico con già messo una
tassa ma la corrente elettrica mi sembra
che sia leggermente tassare bene allora
noi abbiamo la meccanica italiana
elettromagnetismo sono due poli ti
funziona perfettamente
ma sono uno in contrasto con quanto per
risolvere il contrasto ci vuole anche
quello che vale e foresta interessa nel
1905 e feci di un anno quello che ci
sono anche poi impreviste e fra queste
cose fece la dinamica di corpi in
movimento tra di stretta e uguale invece
410 citare l'effetto fotoelettrico fatto
foto elettrico e per ogni altra sorte
perché noi vogliamo alla quantistica
diceva quantistica di cemento cardati
però l'effetto 4 etico scusa che sono
l'esempio un primo della lista
ora è quello che mancava alla rispetta
che lo era la gravitazione non c'è
un'organizzazione e nel 1900 vince è
finalmente fa la svolta è andato
veramente oltre perché parla della
trazione grath nazionale non più come
forza ma come effetto giocato quindi noi
sentiamo una radicazione ma perché in
realtà viviamo uno spazio a quattro
dimensioni che è cupo e stato detto che
la massa dice uno spazio tempo di
occuparsi e lo spazio tempo e dice alla
massa come muoversi
e allora succede succede che la zone
curva lo spazio tempo e santoni e la
terra ne risulta essere intrappolata in
questa deformazione di questa curvatura
si chiama e quindi si muove in orbita
grazie alla deformazione dello spazio
tempo come sempre
la matematica a queste affermazioni è
pubblica e dal caos dal in prima tv the
beast e allora e 1915 prima guerra
mondiale era di fece conoscere le
informazioni da dalla germania ma un
pitching l'eseguito rimasi colpito dalla
triade letale le disse ma se si può fa
lo spazio tempo con un'altra luce
e cosa ci sembrava sparisse e organizzò
due missioni una il brasile non è magica
per vedere se la vedo perché se la neve
non si curava la luce delle stelle
nascosto durante l'eclisse canzone che
volevano assolutamente simili
e così le stelle hanno visivi anni è
stata mia canzone e quindi con la morte
fosse feinstein perché la rivalità
generale funziona ma è andato oltre ha
dato prima tv dalle 16 realizza e le
equazioni complicatissime della rivalità
in generale e trova la soluzione della
soluzione sole con diventa allora dico
solo questo prime nazionali
avete che una carica promesso una carica
elettrica accennata del vostro cellulare
in un competitore determina lunga di
come questo mondo libero maniera viaggia
sullo spazio e si propaga sulla base
invece in generale due massi accelerate
come la carne da determinano un ora ma è
un veliero nota di quanto
diciamo c'è luca che è di forma nello
spazio tecnico da una parte lo allunga e
d'altra parte lo accorcia e viceversa
quindi è una volta dello spazio non è
l'unica in sullo spazio ok
qual è l'effetto in questura non è
l'effetto che vuoi vedere qual è quello
di formare alla terra in questa maniera
l'effetto di in onda della nazionale
cambia la distanza terra sole che di 150
milioni di chilometri dal privato allora
adesso anzi ascolto della difficoltà
prima ha detto al dire e non esiste tra
voi lo ha confutato incroci uscite
paradiso che l'uomo deve fare ma c'è
sempre chi sono sempre gli scienziati
che cerco andare lui e negli anni
sessanta ciò se per la cucina il suo
laboratorio realizzò una palla risonante
uno strumento che secondo chi dovrà
vedere le autorizzazioni e affettuosa
perbenisti e non voglio fu creduto dalla
dalla cometa scientifica ha ragione
perché era visto della casa school però
il trigger fu il calcio inizio di una
nuova avventura una serie di fisici
funzionali rivai scrittori la non vive
negli stati uniti e alla partita zone ma
pisa rehn
francia deciso che era ora di studiare e
poi realizzare il deby tetto per vedere
l'operazione fu è stato realizzato laico
e virtù del 94 in questa avventura e
questo è il risultato di questa cultura
vintage questo evento picco che sta
dicevo pisa è unita nazionale di 3 km
per te iol.it nella terra pisana e
ovviamente sono stato per 20 anni i
lavori mediani da un laboratorio negli
anni conferenze meeting molto
frequentati e anche delle attività
sociali della nostra piccola piccola
comunità
ma il 14 dicembre 2015 è successo
qualcosa del giocatore cìè settembre
abbiamo visto questo questa cosa e
queste sono viste del due per lato
rialimentato operativi live alle alyson
in lousiana il più onesto vi sta bene
abbiamo visto due buchi neri per di una
massa di venti solari di vento nostro
povero soldato 36 che dopo una danza for
ticosa comuni come quadri miliardi di
anni luce da noi recitavano virgola più
l'uno verso l'altro e precisato all'ansa
che la metà della velocità della luce
il quello che succedeva e che vedete lo
spazio tempo quella trasfigurazione
escort equatoriale del fatturato è una
nuova funzione trova lo spazio serbo
intorno alle tre buchi neri si deforma
terribilmente e questi li conosco fondo
di un solo neo di 62 masse sopra ora 36
29 passa facile e abbiamo
dove soprattutto tre soli sono evaporati
energia di roma è uguale a 10 43 soli
sono di incrementare la massa in cui
l'energia che è stata irradiata in tutto
l'universo
nell'ultima frazione di secondo una
potenza pari a 100 mila miliardi di
miliardi di sole ha illuminato tutto
l'universo della noce scura una luce non
visibile di onde delle canzoni
proprio allora punti a 3 milioni di anni
luce da gravitazionale già chi viaggia
di misurata indisturbato a diversi
interventi a proprio agio galassie
stelle attraverso a terra e attraversa
tutti noi e alle 11 50 attraverso il 15
un'ora dopo un giovane ricercatore
italiano che lavora in germania violando
tutte le regole discutere secondi di
confidenza ma a tutta la collaborazione
è stato visto qualcosa di interessante
intorno di questo sono stati sei mesi di
suppone che non ci aspettavamo di
investigazione perché siamo scettici
quindi abbiamo investigato saladino
ansia e citazioni incontri scontri di
una teleconferenza al giorno con
centinaia di fisici negli stati uniti e
in europa
gioia quando avevo capito che avevo
visto che soddisfazione quando andava a
vincere
e allora voi capite quest'anno ne dice
alla fine della bella storia no
all'inizio dell'agosto perché con le
logiche nazionali abbiamo un uomo mondo
guardano diversa abbiamo modo di
guardare lorenzo che entra dentro le
stelle dove la luce non può passare la
luce ne sta dentro la stella non
assorbita dagli strati più esterni
quindi noi vediamo sua mente la buccia
della seconda della stecca invece una
lezione vogliamo entrare tempo oppure
possiamo vedere cosa all'inizio
dell'universo
dipende dipende risultato accessibile
allegretta magnetiche c'è un muro di
plasma o pato alla luce 380.000 anni
dopo il big bang
le una decretazione dello bene possiamo
vedere l'istante iniziali del la
relazione di personale quindi è stata
vent'anni la conclusione di vent anni
della mia vita e dell'abitare che
un migliaio di altri bisogna lì che
hanno iniziato a durare sicuramente però
l'inizio della nuova era che vedrà nuovi
strumenti questo momento quindi caro
prezzo è sicuramente la famiglia
benissimo la fisica e pallido 20 dei
ragazzi del futuro grazie